bonjour à tous il y a quelques semaines
j'ai fêté mon anniversaire j'ai fait mes
30 ans et une amie m'a offert cette
carte
cette carte c'est un peu comme le
calendrier de l'avent au louvre on sait
pas ce qu'il ya dedans avant alors gelé
ouvert et ce qui était notée life does
not have to be perfect obi-wan la foule
ce qui signifie la vie n'a pas besoin
d'être parfaite pour être merveilleuse
je sais pas vous mais moi je suis
vraiment d'accord avec cette citation
est il y a quelque chose en croit en
quoi je crois encore plus c'est que la
vie a besoin d'être positive pour pour
être merveilleuse alors voilà ma
spécialité à moi c'est la positivité
je vais commencer par illustrer la
positivité avec cette image
j'entends des réactions oui c'est du
vent l'idée est d'illustrer le verre à
moitié vide et le verre à moitié plein
j'ai pas pris de l'eau j'ai pris du vin
ici moi ce que je vois c'est deux verres
depuis je suis tout jeune on me demande
et j'imagine que vont vous l'a déjà
demandé aussi est ce que tu es plutôt le
verre à moitié vide ou le verre à moitié
plein et honnêtement je n'ai jamais su
répondre une fois je répondais l'un puis
l'autre
puis l'an histoire de donner une réponse
alors voilà mon interprétation de cette
image pour moi le verre à moitié plein
c'est chouette c'est dynamique le ver se
remplit c'est en mouvement et ça y va
mon interprétation du verre à moitié
plein c'est top
il ya de l'espace il ya des opportunités
c'est génial
comme vous le voyez mes deux
interprétations sont positives et c'est
ma façon de voir la vie
alors voilà avant de parler de la
positivité
on va parler de la négativité la
négativité les français la connaissent
très bien
on est assez réputée pour être à l'heure
j'imagine que vous allez pas me
contredire là dessus alors pour
comprendre ça pourquoi les français les
humains en viennent
ayral se concentre plus sur le négatif
que le positif il faut remonter il ya
des années et des années en arrière
lorsque l'humain devait survivre
oomu règne animal il devait en
permanence être aux aguets des dangers
potentiels et donc pour ça l'humain fait
appel à son cerveau reptilien qui est le
cerveau de l'intuition et de l'instinct
de survie
les personnes qui ont survécu du coup
sont ceux qui ont plus développé ce
cerveau reptilien et donc l'émotion liée
à ça c'est l'anxiété les personnes les
plus luxueuses sont celles qui ont
survécu il y a des centaines d'années ce
trait d'anxiété s'est transmis de
génération en génération
aujourd'hui on l'a tous mais on en a
plus autant besoin qu auparavant
voilà d'où vient la négativité la
pratique et je vais vous montrer comment
on pratique notre négativité pratiquer
sa négativité
c'est super facile il suffit de se
concentrer sur tout ce dont vous manque
et que ce soit un appartement trop petit
pas assez d'amis pas assez d'amour pas
assez de ci et de ça concentrez-vous
bien dessus et vous verrez vous serez au
top au niveau de la négativité et puis
si jamais il ya un événement un peu trop
positif qui vient s'incruster dans votre
vie négative surtout surtout surtout
concentrez vous sur le fait que vous
pouvez le perdre et toutes les peurs qui
viennent avec ça vous l'avez compris la
négativité
c'est facile pour nous alors voilà être
négatif il y a des effets les effets
sont assez naturel je pense qu'on vous
le ressent tous on se sent lourd on a un
noeud dans l'estomac
ça nous fatigue on peut être triste
voilà les effets de la négativité et ses
émotions sont très ancrés dans notre
corps du coup elles restent avec le
temps
j'imagine que vous pouvez repenser de
temps en temps si vous entendez une
musique vous sentez une odeur ça va vous
rappeler un souvenir un souvenir négatif
vous allez être triste ça vous faire
pleurer
et paf le corps le saisit directement
voici les effets de la négativité
alors voilà maintenant je vous propose
de passer à la positivité
c'est quand même plus chouette avant de
plonger encore plus dans la positivité
je vais vous illustrez pourquoi je crois
que la positivité fait une vie
absolument merveilleuse
il y a quatre en cinq ans actuellement
je suis parti au canada en expatriation
à vancouver là bas ils parlent
uniquement en anglais et mon niveau
d'anglais
quand je suis arrivé était vraiment pas
top
du coup je me suis immergé j'ai fait des
efforts j'ai travaillé mon anglais est
là aujourd'hui le niveau d'anglais que
j'ai je n'aurais jamais pu penser la
voir il ya cinq ans et du coup je me
suis posé des questions c'est là où j'ai
eu ce déclic
qu'est-ce qui a fait que mon niveau
d'anglais et pu arriver là alors que
vraiment je lui aurais jamais pensé
j'ai fait quelques recherches et ça m'a
amené il ya soixante dix ans en arrière
en 1949 il y à un psychologue qui
s'appelle donald est bon qui est
canadien et qui s'est intéressé à notre
cerveau qui essayait de comprendre
comment on pouvait manipuler orienté
décider ce qu'on fait avec notre cerveau
et il a découvert la plasticité
cérébrale
la plasticité cérébrale c'est une partie
de votre cerveau avec laquelle vous
faites ce que vous voulez et c'est celle
que j'ai sollicités quand j'ai appris
l'anglais au canada cette platine
plasticité cérébrale elle est
complètement malléable alors voilà il y
a maintenant des effets non pardon
et donc cette plasticité cérébrale
maintenant je vais vous donner comment
pratiquer et comment travailler cette
plasticité cérébrale parce que oui ça se
travaille tout comme la positivité
je vais vous donner quatre conseils
aujourd'hui la première c'est la
gratitude
j'imagine que vous en avez tous entendu
parler la gratitude c'est le fait de
reconnaître ce qui s'est passé de
positif pendant la journée je la
travaille au quotidien depuis trois ans
pour mes 27 ans j'ai reçu incarné par
des amis que je trouve plutôt joli et je
me suis dit que j'allais la pratique est
ce que je fais tous les jours avant
d'aller me coucher je repense à ce qui
s'est passé pendant la journée
les journées passent super vite il se
passe plein de choses
l'idée c'est de noter ce qui s'est passé
de positif dans la journée en l'otan ça
me permet aussi de m'endormir dans des
conditions positives d'avoir une qualité
de sommeil meilleur et de me réveiller
dans de meilleures conditions
je la travaille tous les jours depuis
trois ans alors oui ça m'arrive
d'oublier ont reçu juste humaine comme
vous et du coup ce que je fais je le
fais le lendemain matin ou des fois je
fais deux jours pour 1 ça c'est le
premier conseil
le deuxième conseil je vais l'illustré
avec ma main là vous voyez ma main ce
côté une montre et des bagues une main
moi j'ai une autre perspective qui est
celle là un petit soleil
l'idée ici c'est vous montrez que vous
faites ce que vous voulez avec une
situation c'est vous qui décidez la
perspective est l'angle de vue dans
laquelle vous voulez regarder une
situation un autre conseil
l'idée c'est de repenser heinz une
réaction vous avez eue avec laquelle
vous n'êtes pas confortable une réaction
qui est donc négative ici je vous invite
à faire une pause
j'ai repensé à cette réaction à
l'émotion présentes qui étaient là pour
vous et à repenser à un scénario positif
quelle émotion que vous auriez aimé
avoir quelle est la réaction que vous
auriez aimé avoir
à force de travail et ça ça va inculquer
en vous des choses positives et des
réactions positives dernier conseil et
celui là je vous invite à le faire dès
ce soir quand vous rentrez chez vous
vous prenez une feuille blanche et vous
noté tous vos succès tout ce lait tous
les succès que vous avez eu au cours de
votre vie et ensuite toutes les qualités
et les forces que vous avez et vous le
mettez sur votre frigo
l'idée ici c'est d'afficher ce dont vous
êtes fier parce que comme on l'a vu on a
tendance à ce focus et et à se
concentrer sur la négativité en
affichant sa vous le verrez au quotidien
vous le lisez vous en faites ce que vous
voulez mais ce sera là et ça vous envoie
des ondes positives
alors voilà mes quatre conseils ensuite
c'est bien beau la positivité
mais franchement ça sert à quoi quels
sont les effets les effets il y en a
plusieurs géants partager quelques-uns
avec vous
le premier effet c'est le cercle
vertueux
plus il y as positif dans votre vie plus
vous êtes concentrer sur le positif et
moins vous avez des espaces pour le
négatif c'est cercle vertueux qui se
fait automatiquement un deuxième effet
positif
la résilience la résilience et la
capacité à résister à des événements
douloureux ou difficiles les personnes
positives liées à leur façon de voir les
choses à la perspective ont une
meilleure résilience au challenge de la
vie alors oui les personnes positives
n'ont pas une vie bisounours on est tous
une vie avec des up and down c'est juste
la vie des personnes positives ont une
meilleure perspective sur ces moments
challenging un autre effet de la
positivité
c'est la vie sociale les personnes
positives liées à la gratitude et leur
façon de voir la vie tissent des liens
sociales de meilleure qualité avec leurs
amis il y à un ted qui existe à propos
de ce qui rend les gens heureux
est ce que c'est la voiture est ce que
c'est le statut social le métier fut
désolé je vais vous spoiler mais c'est
la qualité des relations sociales
pas la quantité mais la qualité le
dernier effet c'est la confiance en soi
une personne positive va toujours voir
le côté positif des choses et lors d'un
échec
elle va pas le voir comme un échec mais
plutôt comme une expérience de vie et un
apprentissage
juste une étape à passer pour continuer
dans la vie des effets positifs à la
positivité
il y en a encore plein d'autres
l'innovation la créativité et la
mémorisation
ok on a vu la négativité on a vu la
positivité
mais la base de tout ça c'est quoi ce
sont les émotions les émotions une
émotion
c'est un message qui est envoyé poule
par votre corps pour vous donner une
information
et si là maintenant tout de suite il est
14h30
vous vous concentrez sur l'émotion qui
est présente pour vous maintenant est ce
que vous êtes plutôt dans la joie est ce
que vous êtes plutôt dans la peur dans
la lassitude qu'elle est l'émotion qui
est là pour vous maintenant dites vous
que cette émotion elle est déjà parti
une émotion ne dure que quelques
secondes ce qui prend le relais à
l'émotion c'est la mémoire c'est les
pensées rumine hâtif qui vont entretenir
cette émotion
je vais vous donner un exemple le mois
dernier j'étais en déplacement avec des
collègues au texas on a pris un hubert
et j'étais assise à l'arrière
au milieu je vois les voitures freiné
devant mes collègues qui discutait avec
le chauffeur est là montez montez ventes
s'est mis à se serrer j'ai commencé à
être angoissé parce que je voyais
l'accident venir finalement lui le
chauffeur a vu qu'il y avait les
voitures qui ralentissait et s'est mis à
freiner il nous est rien arrivé
et mon cerveau a commencé à paniquer
mais si on avait eu un accident et qu'il
aurait pu en arriver là j'ai fait le
choix de me dire non je ne veux pas
donner d'importance à cette émotion qui
de toute façon ne sert plus à rien la
solution est résolu et le choix c'est à
ce moment là que vous vous lavez de
faire le choix lorsqu une émotion vient
de choisir la positivité ou la
négativité
la positivité
selon mon point de vue c'est comme cette
goutte d'eau qui tombent dans l'eau font
ça se répercute 16 diffuse on peut
prendre l'exemple
si vous êtes avec une personne qui
rigole ou qui sourit ça vous donne envie
de rigoler et sourire et la positivité
c'est exactement pareil lorsque vous
êtes une personne positive
vous avez de l'impact sur les personnes
autour de vous qui elles mêmes vont
avoir de l'impact sur les personnes
autour d'elle alors quel est l'impact
que vous décidez d'avoir aujourd'hui
merci
[Applaudissements]